[Music]  not interested it is gonna change spying  forever imagine if I can make you wait  for it drumroll please disappear  disappear yeah  disappear why are you saying it like  that for a fee I'm totally excited about  it it's called biodynamic concealment  boom mic drop  good conceal this I mean you wouldn't  need a boat for shoot would you make  exploding cufflinks you can blend in  anywhere  Wow  dude that's a mess  [Music]  let the beat drop I was the world's  greatest spy sleepy night night but then  you turn me into a pigeon you better  unburden eat right now you kind of bird  it yourself oh there's a bad guy who  needs to be stopped and now I have to  try to stop him while being a bird lucky  for you I'm your wingman  Wow  [Music]  let's get weird  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  all right Kimora starting it's about to  get messy  time to go sleepy night  [Music]  I miss my hands  [Music]